[Music]
again and welcome to steampunks
GameSpot's PT polka show with just
McDonnell and myself
Edmund Tran we talk about the world of
PC gaming and give you some times we
give you recommendations on stuff you
know we talk about things and stuff
everything anyway so show me 1 & 2 came
out this week on a lot of consoles on PC
as well which it's pretty interesting
because what is it is it like a remake
it's not really it's not really a
remaster either because it's basically
just the same game as it was it just
runs on PC yeah and so the topic this
week is do remasters make sense with PC
yeah and beyond that are we a fan of
remakes in remasters there's a lot of
talk especially in the PC realm we've
got things like mods re masters
necessary when are they necessary when
did they change enough would know enough
and I'll be changing in the right ways
yeah obviously it makes sense for an old
console game that was on the ps2 or ps3
to get up you know remastered and sort
of made to work on a new console that's
great but with PC you know it's always
kind of gonna work as long as you have
the same kind of hardware and you know
maybe you might need to use like an OS
emulator or something like that but for
the most part games kind of like aged
really well on PC obviously back in the
80s and 90s where computers had sort of
CGA and EGA displays and then things got
advanced we had vga like full color sort
of graphics capabilities a lot of
classic adventure games and classic
games in general got big remix into sort
of like full sort of much better-looking
sort of variants of their own cells and
in some cases they their systems change
completely so i'm thinking of things
like the original King's Quest and Space
Quest X plus with glory games which used
to be like text parser games because you
know not many people had mice back then
that they remade a lot of those classic
original adventure games into a
point-and-click stylings of faced with
beautiful graphics and you know all that
kind of stuff yeah I think also fitting
into that realm one of my very favorite
games Sid Meier's pirate I actually
began as a game you may have may not
know all from the Commodore 64 back in
the late 80s and it was remastered twice
once to give it a little graphics push
and if you played the 2004
addition gorgeous-looking game now I
would say still holds up today but
retained what made the game so great
then it was a highly critically
acclaimed game then they retained and
held that magic and turned it into
something that I think is still so much
fun to play just a really strong concept
and strong gameplay obviously we're
talking about games that existed before
the 3d kind of era so a lot of like 2d
art which was really low resolution
remaking those kind of games like mist
and ribbon and that kind of stuff into
more high fidelity assets I mean that
that's beautiful they're in a 3d realm
the only kind of real examples I can
think of where a PCB master might be
really good is in two cases either one
where a game that was previously only
console exclusive gets remastered and
bought to PC and PC owners who don't own
consoles can actually experience that
stuff for the first time as is the case
with Shenmue 1 and 2 as well as a lot of
other Sega and Capcom titles that have
come to PC very recently including
Valkyria Chronicles yeah physical ami
and zero as well as they will may cry
that in that kind of example it's just a
matter of Japanese instead of game
manufacturers who previously only focus
on consoles realizing that there is a
market there their games in the PC space
as well so as we move on that's probably
going to become a more rare example of
remastering the second example I can
think of where PC remarking is really
useful is in terms of making yeah those
old PC games available again and in a in
a form that runs very easily for like
USU standard sort of consumer PC Gamer
yeah I think steam and GOG are doing a
pretty good job at that but just like in
order to be able to easily access having
that game once again and just knowing
that it's going to run smoothly because
modding is always available and I think
there are a lot of cases for example
Heroes of Might and Magic 3 excellent
game received a remastered edition I
think a year or two ago wasn't great I
think the same story with another great
game Age of Empires when that got its
remastered edition it just wasn't
exactly what the fans wanted in the case
of Heroes they lost the code for the
expansion so the beloved expansions
which add tons of content one of a
in the remastered edition that said both
of those things have very active modding
communities on PC that were just doing a
better job at changing things and I
think it was the same story when a
Skyrim remastered arrived for the PC
players yeah that was always confusing
one yeah it is and it made sense for the
console players but for those of us who
were already playing on PC and probably
we're using mods it didn't make much of
a difference but if you didn't like mods
I think it is good that the options
available
yeah on the flip side of that coin you
have examples of games like grim fandago
that's Tim shape is kind of like one of
his really his best adventure games
which was a Windows 95 title and was
impossible to run on modern pcs and less
you are really good at modding and
that's fine but having them buy back the
rights and making sure it runs now and
sort of having an official package that
just works straight out of the box is
way less of a headache than the hoops
you had to go through to actually get it
playable in mine systems and that also
goes for adventure games that get lost
in sort of rights and licensing limbo
like Sam and Max and full throttle also
advange in that adventure game space
that I'm just nice to have like legally
you know like those things got passed
around in torrents and file-sharing yeah
sites for a long time before they
actually got released and it's nicely
like give back to Tim Schafer and Double
Fine food making those really great
classic games that were a big part of
you know a lot of people's childhoods
yeah it's also great for the devs to
have a hand in it as well I mean cuz you
get stuff like hey we know the controls
are a pain in the also grim fandango we
fixed them like it's nice obviously the
community had already expressed that but
it's nice for the developers themselves
to want to iterate on their classic
games Age of Empires - you know like
Microsoft finally made multiplayer work
and I guess the other thing that needs
to be addressed is like do we really
want remasters I mean they're become so
common so common in the last five years
it's been to the point where we go to
shows like III and we're expecting
remasters you're not new IP or new games
in series and I think there's the
question of whether they're valuable or
whether it's something that's a cash-in
or a waste of the developer or
publishers time when they could be
making something near I think there's
two sides to that coin obviously it is
it is a cheap cash in and you know
especially the console versions because
if you love Devil May Cry maybe you want
to buy the ps4 version as well but it's
also a way of sort of
gauging interest in a franchise that's
kind of hasn't done anything for a while
and I get that business side of it so in
the Devil May Cry example they released
various remastered version on ps3 and I
get on ps4 and you know like a lotta
people bought those and now what's
happened is that one may cry five is
coming out you know and no one really
expected that way no chit chat or
monologue just getting right to the
point that it's really easy to be
cynical about remasters in this day and
age but it's you always have to remember
that remasters really helped into
preserving like really really great
classic games
yeah sure Dark Souls in Skyrim got you
know remasters like only a few years
after their the initial release but
these are modern classics that people
are gonna be wanting to play for a long
long time and if you know changing a
little bit of code and giving them a
better official texture pack helps in
that long run then maybe we'll be you
know thanking Namco and Bethesda you
know 10 20 30 years down the line I mean
that's just what we think let us know in
the comments what you think about
remasters whether you've played a good
remaster lately whether you think
they're completely useless or what games
you really want to be remaster don't
baby see I bet you know how about have a
mil on those kind of thoughts and we'll
be back next week with another PC
related topic I don't know what its
gonna be maybe you should tell us what
it is
I've been till then goodbye
[Music]